uh well technically you always knew she
was sisu
seriously princess warrior raya
it doesn't matter what you refer to her
as the impact her characters had on
people across the globe is impressive
but what is the true origin of ryan the
last dragon in today's video we're
uncovering how the story of ray and her
companions came to be and why it's so
groundbreaking for not only disney but
for all of hollywood
and yet these characters really go out
of their way and risk
everything
the idea to have raya and plenty of
other characters be warrior women was
inspired by the vietnamese story of the
trung sisters
they led an uprising in ad39 against
imperial china and even held power over
an independent state for a time
iconic adele says these women were
definitely brought up during the
creation process
southeast asia has this amazing
tradition of like strong female warriors
and strong female leaders
in the last few years we've seen the
disney narrative change and give us a
fresh new version
of what it means to be a disney princess
in films like moana frozen
and brave but the creators took raya's
story even further
their goal was to craft an epic
character that made people really
question what it means to be a princess
and a warrior what do people think when
they think of the word princess
what do people think when they think of
the word hero they took inspiration from
southeast asian culture but they made
sure they didn't fall into the stoic
warrior misconception that other western
movies have done in the past
according to writer adele lim raya is
basically an embodiment of all the
strong southeast asian women she had in
her life growing up
you're friends with asian moms or you
know southeast asian aunties like
they'll tell you how strong they are and
how influential they are in their lives
basically raya is as real as it gets
okay now we can do this i'm ready i know
exactly how we'll stop then
no one can say raya's character wasn't
thoroughly thought out everything down
to her name was chosen with precision
adele said they wanted to find a name
that resonated across multiple cultures
in southeast asia
raya just clicked in malaysia raya
translates into celebration
and reminded them about the lively
communities that a lot of southeast
asian cultures form
and in southern thailand raya can be a
name to call the one who leads
how fitting for a warrior princess
you're
glowing oh thank you raya's creators
were also not afraid to really dive into
the complexity of female relationships
something that we don't see much of it
was important to them to have female
characters where gender was never an
obstacle
they said our characters are female
that's part of their identity but it is
not their sole defining trait
not only was raya the protagonist a
woman but so was their antagonist amari
to mix it up even more these two women
had a deep history of love and
friendship
raya wasn't just a hero and namari
wasn't just a villain
as adele put it they are free fully
fleshed out characters
it made for such a soulful story and
their complicated relationship was like
a breath of fresh air to watch
overall raya's journey and the entire
film's theme is trust
ironically the movie ended up coming out
at a time where it couldn't be more
relatable
a divided community searching for the
answer to restoring unity
if that isn't 2020 and 2021 in a
nutshell we don't know what is
raya had to learn too is better than one
qui says
we're better together than apart that
you know that there's a value and
there's a bravery in
trusting people but even before the
pandemic they knew that the important
message and running theme was going to
be trusting others
no you're so connected to the gems magic
speaking of trust raya has to rely on
water dragon sisu throughout a lot of
the movie
the inspiration behind sisu the
southeast asian myth of naga
but they had the idea to make her
animation look like what she represented
to the culture
rather than what naga is actually meant
to look like she embodies magic and
inspirations and overall is supposed to
be larger than life
and aquafina's voiceover just brings
sisu to the next level
in fact aquafina said she didn't realize
until people started to point it out but
sisu's attitude might have been
subconsciously inspired by robin
williams's version of the genie
that's a very flattering comparison i i
obviously
genie was a huge staple of my childhood
while we're talking about the myths and
legends that inspired raya and the last
dragon
let's dive into what else the creators
were influenced by the research for this
film
was extensive they created the south
asia story trust which had the crew
traveling to countries like laos
indonesia thailand vietnam cambodia
malaysia
and singapore artists architects
anthropologists and a bunch of other
southeast asian cultural experts joined
them so that they'd really be able to
grasp all the different cultures
they immediately noticed the same
running theme of community that all the
different countries had
so that was one of their main priorities
to bring to the screen
of course kamandra is fictional but the
culture is one that was made up of very
real worldly places
from the color palettes that the
characters donned all the way to the
magic of the night markets
everything had a reason for being
included they even sourced inspiration
for their martial arts fight scenes
the level of action in this movie is
pretty tight their writer
quigwin ended up being a southeast asian
martial arts specialist
score he said it was important to make
sure that all the martial arts scenes
were realistic and accurate
especially because you don't really see
southeast asian martial arts on screen
just listen to how much thought went
into it you see weapons get pulled out
from raya that are skrima that come from
the philippines
in the end raya's fighting style ended
up being based on indonesia's panchak
silat
and namari's on muay thai when rai was
fighting with her father
it was a trust-filled and bonding moment
so it was filmed differently and in a
different light than any other action
scenes
what's up my new customers i'm captain
boone
the overall message that these creators
wanted to bring to the screen was about
pulling people together
giving a message about hope and never
giving up well
little did they know that they'd have to
do just that to actually make the movies
possible
when the kovan 19 pandemic hit they had
to rework how they were going to
actually make this happen
spoiler alert it wasn't easy
the actors set up a makeshift recording
studio in their homes
some people spent their days working
from their closet including kelly marie
tran
recording from home has been really fun
but there have been some hard things
that's right raya was basically brought
to life in a closet
well at least her voice was kelly even
kept a production diary so she could
remember how bizarre it was
and he was like can you get this tent
out of my house please for aquafina
she set up an entire tent in her home
and her cat
wasn't exactly happy about the new
addition to the space even sandra oh
noticed
nora it's like union cat i know why
wasn't my me and my cat
just like the actors the producers and
animators and the rest of the crew of
more than
400 people 400 people
were all working from home they would be
on constant zoo meetings where they
would share ideas
their recent animations and basically
anything else that had to be done
except they were joined by their furry
friends babies and roommates
it might have been a challenge but we
gotta say watching raya and the last
dragon
you could never tell that it was
completely produced outside of a studio
animation on this movie is on a totally
different level
that's what you call talent despite the
situation they had to make the film in
how important it was to the cast and
crew especially those of southeast asian
culture never wavered adele lim couldn't
believe that after 20 years
she was finally able to bring to life a
character she could see herself
in that represented her culture she
thinks this movie is a
huge move in the right direction when it
comes to seeing more representation
thing that is so much bigger than me
that has so much legacy behind it
kelly marie tran couldn't agree more she
also never grew up seeing herself in the
disney films she watched and said
i think young me would have been really
proud of where i am today and what i'm
trying to do
as for the audience it's just as
meaningful
even interviewers are expressing how
emotional they got watching something
they could relate to unfold on screen
like emotional actually when i saw the
characters come out and they look like
uncles and aunts and cousins of mine
raya's character
is a huge game changer there's no doubt
about it
in fact we're willing to bet she'll go
down in history as not only one of
disney's most iconic princesses
but is one of their most diverse and
complex characters
with an ever-changing industry we can't
wait to see what other groundbreaking
characters disney will continue to
deliver
what was your favorite part about raya
and the last dragon